The execution of the pirate king Gol D. Roger
and the execution of his son Portgas D. Ace.
One happens right at the beginning of the
story sparking the great pirate era, the other
right in the middle, plunging the world into
an era of chaos and war.
So wouldn’t it make sense, if there was
one final execution that would ring in an
era of freedom and peace for the entire world,
near the end of One Piece as well?
And at this point in the story, there is only
one person, that the government is as desperate
to execute as the first pirate king.
Which leaves us with a super intriguing question:
What would happen, if Luffy was about to be
executed by the Marines?
Who would come to his rescue?
And what would this second version of Marineford
look like?
Imagine this: It is some time after Luffy
has just defeated Kaido.
He has officially been labeled a Yonko and
has awakened his legendary devil fruit.
So you might be wondering, how would the world
government ever capture him?
Well, there are a few options of how this
could happen.
He could be betrayed by one of his allies
or even be blackmailed if one of his friends
has been kidnapped.
But for the sake of this video, let’s just
assume that someone has drugged his pile of
meat which knocks Luffy out cold.
He is then carried away during the night and
onto a government ship.
Next they slap on their strongest sea prism
stone, submerge Luffy in a tank of water,
tie him down with chains, and keep him guarded
by an admiral and Seraphim.
Certainly that should be enough to keep any
devil fruit user contained.
And now that he’s captured, we have to ask
why would the World Government want to execute
Luffy in the first place?
Well, to start, he has already publicly declared
war on the WG, he assaulted a world noble,
he is the son of Dragon, the most wanted man
in the world, and he is a Yonko with a 3 billion
berry bounty.
On top of all that, executing Luffy would
be a symbol to the world that the government
still owns the seas, just like they did with
Roger and Ace’s executions.
And if that isn’t enough, they would definitely
want to eliminate the awakened Nika fruit
user because of his ties to Joy Boy and the
void century.
To sum it up, Luffy is the biggest current
threat to the World Government and their control
of the world.
So with Luffy on a ship heading to New Marineford,
where they plan to carry out the execution,
the World Government announces to the world
that Luffy will be put to death in a few days
time.
Now you might be wondering why in the world
they would choose a public execution AGAIN
after they almost lost the war at Marineford.
Well, it is really quite simple.
You see, a public execution is about more
than just killing someone, it is a symbol
of power and control.
So by executing Luffy with the whole world
watching, the world government is sending
a message to all pirates that no matter how
strong you are, the world government cannot
be defeated.
As for why they choose New Marineford as the
location, you will see exactly why they choose
this spot later in the video.
But first, what about the other straw hats?
Well, while they are strong, they aren’t
powerful enough to take on the entire of the
marine forces and rescue Luffy by themselves.
Instead, they immediately try to contact as
many of their friends as possible and tell
them that Luffy needs their help.
And by friends, we mean ALL OF THEIR FRIENDS.
[show most of the chibi’s, perhaps some
of the more uncertain allies silhouetted]
A pretty impressive group.
Are the marines seriously even going to stand
a chance?
Well, the marines have many impressive fighters
themselves plus the new Seraphim, who are
advanced clones of the former Warlords, that
we were introduced to right after Wano.
[show chibi’s of the marines, in order like
a pyramid.
Vice-admirals.
Seraphim.
Admirals.
Kong and Gorosei on top.
Imu above them?]
But while most characters can be clearly divided
into either allies or enemies, there are many
that have uncertain loyalties.
For example, what would Garp do if Luffy was
about to be executed?
We already saw that he could barely contain
himself when Ace was killed, so would he really
stand by and let his last remaining grandson
die?
And how about Koby, Smoker, or even Fujitora?
How will they behave on the battlefield?
And speaking of said battlefield, here is
what we know about New Marineford.
This base became the new headquarters after
old marineford was destroyed.
[show map].
It has this massive, many-tiered fortress
surrounded by rocky land.
There are also these huge mcdonalds-shaped
arches and a bridge possibly leading to the
Red Line.
The execution platform with Luffy is right
here [mark him on the second tier above the
gate] guarded by Akainu, Garp and Sengoku.
Most of the marine forces are spread out around
the island, including the Seraphim and Vice-Admirals,
while the admirals wait right here above the
main gate.
And at the top of the structure, Kong makes
his first real appearance to oversee the battle.
And let’s get to that battle.
It is a few days after Luffy was captured.
And with the world watching, the Thousand
Sunny approaches New Marineford.
The straw hats and Sabo, who they picked up
along the way, are lined up at the front of
the ship, determined to save Luffy.
But they are immediately fired upon by every
single cannon on the fortress.
Zoro and Sanji leap up and protect the ship
and in return Franky fires the Gaon Cannon
straight at the admirals.
However, just like in Marineford, they block
the blast.
And before the Sunny can even land, Greenbull
sends out a ton of vines to trap the ship.
Sabo use his flame fruit powers to burn the
vines and those two begin the battle.
The straw hats emerge from the ship and are
immediately met by S-Hawk and S-Flamingo.
Zoro and Sanji take on these Seraphim, while
the other straw hats begin to fight the vice
admirals and Seraphim as they make their way
towards Luffy.
[show straw hats beginning to separate.]
And remember that they are not alone in this
fight.
Prior to the battle, the Straw Hats and the
Grand Fleet gathered to make a coordinated
plan of attack.
And now that the Sunny has landed, the allied
captains join the battle, spreading out to
take on the other main forces of the marines.
The battle is fully on, however, the marines
seem to have the upper hand.
Cannons rain down on the grand fleet.
The seraphim blast allies with lasers.
And all Luffy can do is shout encouragement
and curse the marines.
And with the allies struggling to make progress,
the marines spring their first trap.
Akainu literally erupts into these massive
streams of magma.
The magma lands in three lines around the
island, basically separating the fighters
from each other.
And here’s where I’ll add that even though
we don’t exactly know how these fights would
go, we can reasonably guess how close characters
are in strength.
So while it is possible the allies would be
destroyed, we will assume they are strong
enough to survive… for now.
With the fighters trapped between the magma
and the superheated air above it, the admirals
leap down into each sector and begin the lay
waste to the allies.
Akainu sees that Greenbull’s plants are
no match for Sabo and he swaps places with
the forest Logia user.
Instead, Greenbull enters the sector where
Zoro, Sanji, and Usopp are fighting S-Hawk
and S-Flamingo.
And while Zoro and Sanji are occupied with
the Seraphim, Usopp is left to run for his
life from the admiral.
It’s like he is reliving his worst nightmare
[show training in the forest during the timeskip].
On the other side of the island, Fujitora
seems to be more concerned with saving lives
than he is with attacking Nami, Franky and
Chopper.
Although those three do have to contend with
S-Shark and S-Croc.
No easy feat, although Franky as already fought
against S-Sharks’ Swim-Swim fruit during
his battle of chads with Senor Pink.
This leaves Kizaru free to zip around and
unleash light bombs all around the battlefield.
Yeah, things are not looking good for the
straw hats.
But thankfully, there are more allies on the
way.
Suddenly, a massive blast breath shoots out
of the clouds, destroying all of the cannons
on one side of the fortress.
It seems the pink dragon Momo and Kaido’s
son/daughter were a little late to the battle
after picking up Marco the Phoenix.
And while these three are powerhouses by themselves,
it seems that the Samurai of Wano have stayed
home to protect their island.
Regardless, Momo continues to blast the fortress
until Kizaru comes to confront them.
And while Momo is a large target for the light
Logia user, Yamato and Marco do enough to
keep the admiral at bay while Momo destroys
all of the cannons.
Meanwhile, Kong jumps down next to Luffy,
who is cursing at his Grandpa to let him go.
Because he knows that the way things are going,
his crew and fleet will not survive.
While Zoro and Sanji can fight on par with
the Seraphim, the other straw hats simply
can’t hold out forever.
Robin and Brook combine to fight the shadow
powers of S-Gecko, while Jinbe combines his
Fishman Karate and the nearby water to fight
against S-Snake.
While on the other side of the island, Nami,
Franky, and Chopper have to fight gravity
and the superhuman strength of S-Croc and
S-Shark.
Meanwhile, the Grand fleet is fighting with
the Vice-Admirals Hina, Smoker, Bastille,
Doberman, and Lonz, and they can’t do much
else to help.
In fact, things are about to get much worse.
Akainu momentarily overwhelms Sabo with his
superior magma powers, and Luffy’s brother
is thrown near the sea.
Just like in Marineford, Jinbe steps up to
stop Akainu, but he is no match for the admiral.
With Jinbe distracted, S-Snake is free to
hunt Robin.
The Seraphim brushes aside Robin’s sprouted
limbs and grabs the archaeologist by the throat,
choking the life out of her.
Brook tries to save her, but he is stopped
by S-Gecko.
Robin even tries to enter her demon form,
but S-Snake is just too strong.
However, one marine can no longer just stand
by and watch.
Flying in with a flash of pink hair, Koby
punches S-Snake, sending her crashing to the
rocks.
And our favorite archeologist is free.
Meanwhile, Koby is literally shaking, unsure
of what to do next.
Furious, Akainu comes for Koby.
And the pink haired marine refuses to cower
as he did at Marineford.
However, as Akainu reaches back his fiery
fist, he is blasted by a huge gust of wind.
Everyone on this side of the island stops,
stunned as they see Monkey D. Dragon and the
revolutionary army standing on top of the
bridge.
And while we don’t know exactly what Dragons
powers are, everytime we have seen him in
the story there is strange wind and weather.
So for now let’s assume he has some sort
of wind powers, either from a devil fruit
or an ancient weapon.
Or maybe just the most over powered wind dial
in history ***chuckles**.*
As Dragon looks down on the field, he sends
another blast of wind that almost topples
Akainu.
This gives Sabo enough time to get some healing
from the Tontatta princess Mansherry so he
can get back up and resume his fight with
the fleet admiral.
Meanwhile, Dragon stares at Luffy for a long
moment, but instead of coming to save him,
he turns and makes his way across the bridge
towards the Red Line and Mariejois.
It seems that Dragon sees this chaos as the
opportune moment to fulfill his own plans
of taking down the celestial dragons.
However, he will not get there so easily.
Because this whole time, the Gorosei have
been watching the battle ready to intervene
if necessary.
And now they see a chance to end one of the
most dangerous threats to the world government,
and they intend to take it.
And again, we don’t really know the Gorosei’s
full capabilities yet, but for this video
we are going to assume that they have some
fighting capabilities.
So along with CP0, they begin their battle
with the Revolutionaries.
Now up in the air, Kizaru is finally getting
the better of Momo, Yamato, and Marco.
Momo is burned from multiple light blasts,
and Marco is struggling to keep up with the
light fruit user.
The Grand fleet is being overwhelmed by the
sheer number of vice-admirals and marines.
And while Sanji has defeated S-Flamingo with
his super speed and fiery kicks, Zoro is still
locked in battle with S-Hawk.
And poor Usopp is just barely staying alive
while running and sniping at Greenbull.
Luckily, the straw hats' most powerful allies
are about to arrive.
Buggy the Clown is ready to join the battle.
And while it seems Buggy got a bit lost on
the way to New Marineford, he now stands at
the front of his massive ship giving a passionate
speech about how Cross Guild have come to
take out some marines of their own.
This riles up his men, but while he is distracted,
Kizaru sends a laser shot right towards the
newly crowned Yonko.
Unable to react in time, Buggy is saved by
the sword of his long time friend, Shanks.
Welcome to the party, Red-Haired Pirates.
Shanks leaps onto the battlefield followed
by his crew, Hancock, Rayleigh, as well as
Crocodile and Mihawk, who have come with Buggy.
Shanks immediately heads towards the bridge
where the Revolutionaries are being overrun.
Surely he is going to help Dragon against
the Gorosei, right?
Right???
At the same time, Mihawk begins to fight his
clone which frees Zoro to save Usopp from
Greenbull.
Likewise, Crocodile takes on S-Croc while
Rayleigh and Hancock take over fighting the
Seraphim attacking Robin and Brook.
Up on the fortress, Luffy is thrilled to see
so many of his friends coming to help his
crew, while Garp smolders watching the battlefield
below.
But it is at this point, Kong has seen enough
and he orders Luffy’s immediate execution.
As the announcement spreads across the field,
the straw hats become frantic.
Sanji tries to come help, but Kizaru keeps
him away.
Franky launches a laser beam, but it is easily
blocked by S-Bear.
Zoro manages to defeat Greenbull and leaps
up to the first wall, but he is stopped by
the golden buddha Sengoku.
But now that Usopp is not running for his
life, he climbs a rock and snipes Kong.
However, the Commander in Chief easily tanks
Usopp’s shot.
The executioner’s blades begin to fall,
but Shanks unleashes a Conqueror’s Haki
blast that shakes the island.
Weak characters from both sides fall.
And it is more than enough to knock out the
executioners, who always seem to be these
random dudes **amused tone**.
However, Kong snatches one of the blades and
is about to bring it down on Luffy’s neck.
But unlike at Marineford, Garp isn’t going
to just stand by and watch.
Garp crushes the blade in a haki covered fist,
and the most epic clash of marines begins.
And while we don’t know exactly how strong
Kong is, we are going to assume that he should
be at least a match for Garp.
They throw island-shaking punches, crushing
stone beneath their feet, but eventually Garp’s
intense motivation to save his grandson helps
him win this brawl, and he throws Kong down
to the foot of the bridge.
While all this is happening, Akainu has yet
again overwhelmed Sabo and Koby.
This man is just too strong.
The fleet admiral heads towards Garp and Luffy.
Also, strangely the Gorosei and Kong are retreating
to the Red Line, leaving CP0 to fight the
revolutionaries.
This frees Shanks to confront Akainu and the
two begin the fight we never got to see at
Marineford.
On the other side of the battlefield, Momo
and Yamato have come to help fight Fujitora,
but the blind admiral has become even more
disinterested in fighting and is looking up
into the sky instead.
What could he sense up there?
Now with Kong defeated, Luffy yells for his
grandpa to set him free.
But instead Garp begins to lecture Luffy about
his choice to become a pirate and how he’s
put all of his friends at risk.
After voicing his frustrations, Garp reaches
down to unlock the sea prism stone chains.
However, as he does, blood spurts from his
mouth and a sinister laugh echoes across the
battlefield.
[Blackbeard Laughter]
Luffy shouts in shock as his grandpa topples
over, and suddenly three men become visible
beside the execution platform.
They are Shiryu with his blade dripping blood,
Van Auger – who has the teleportation devil
fruit – and Blackbeard.
Garp coughs blood again, and tries to rise.
But it is too late.
Before the vice-admiral can stand, Blackbeard
takes his pistol and shoots him in the back
over and over again.
This happens right in front of Luffy, until
Garp’s eyes close and he lays still.
Luffy’s eyes waver.
His hair flashes white.
Conqueror’s haki shoots from him like lightning
and the walls tremble.
Suddenly a golden fist descends on the four
pirates as Sengoku roars with rage.
Blackbeard blocks Sengoku’s giant punch
and with his other hand sends out shockwaves
that make the former fleet admiral fall.
Zoro also leaps up and clashes with Shiryu
but Van Auger teleports the three of them
to the other side of the battlefield, leaving
Blackbeard and Luffy alone.
Shouts rise from the battlefield as all eyes
are locked on the two pirate king rivals.
Blackbeard’s darkness-covered fist reaches
down and grabs Luffy by the neck.
Luffy thrashes, trying to break free, but
it is impossible due to Blackbeard’s fruit
and the seastone still weakening him.
Blackbeard takes his pistol, points it at
Luffy’s head, but before he can pull the
trigger, the sky darkens.
Blackbeard stops and looks up, as does everyone
else.
Dark clouds have gathered, but above them
there is some incredible mass of light.
With everyone distracted, God Usopp takes
advantage of the moment.
You see, the wax man Mr. 3 has also arrived
with Cross Guild.
And just like in Marineford, he makes a key
to unlock the sea prism stone handcuffs.
Usopp snipes the key all the way across the
battlefield perfectly into the slot on Luffy’s
handcuffs as he is held up by Blackbeard.
[Click]
And Luffy is free.
***say slowly with emphasis***
Just in time for beams of light to rain down
from the sky.
You see, this was part of the plan all along.
In a situation like this, it would be the
perfect moment for the Gorosei or Imu to use
their super powered weapon capable of destroying
islands.
And the reason they wanted this execution
out in the open just like Marineford was to
gather all the strong pirates of the world,
and wipe them out all at once, even if they
killed many of the marines in the process.
Effectively starting the great cleansing they
mentioned in chapter 908.
And at this point, there are many ways such
an event could go.
The lasers could certainly be strong enough
to kill everyone gathered at New Marineford.
But for this video, we are going to assume
that there is a way to survive.
Enter the enraged Sun god Luffy.
Now fully in his awakened form, Luffy grabs
part of the fortress walls and stretches it
across the sky above the island just as the
lasers come down.
The wall gets obliterated, but it does stop
the lasers.
Rubble falls, destroying the island and many
of the pirates’ ships waiting in the ocean.
Even the massive arches of new marineford
begin to crash to the ground.
It is pure chaos until suddenly the rocks
freeze in mid air.
You see, Fujitora has fully abandoned the
fight and is using his gravity powers to stop
the falling stones.
And at this point survival is on everyone’s
mind.
Can you imagine seeing such destructive powers
nearly wipe everyone out.
Who wouldn’t want to run?
Members of the grand fleet return to the ships
that are still intact.
The revolutionaries do the same.
Even the Red-Hair pirates are rallying around
Shanks near the shore.
Everyone just wants to escape with their lives
as this terrifying power lights up the sky
once more.
Well, everyone except Luffy.
Laughing uncontrollably – and with tears
in his eyes – he protects Garp’s body
from the falling stones and lashes out at
Blackbeard.
The punch sends Blackbeard flying, but the
Yonko is caught by VanAuger and brought safely
to the ground.
Luffy chases Blackbeard and this brings him
close to where Shanks and Akainu have paused
their fight.
Luffy and Blackbeard clash once again, shaking
the island with their titanic powers.
Nearby, Shanks yells at Luffy to stop fighting.
And even Akainu is looking up at the sky as
he moves towards the bridge and the safety
of the Red Line with the rest of the marines.
[move the marines on the map]
But Luffy continues to pummel Blackbeard until
he is once again teleported by VanAuger out
to their ship waiting offshore.
Luffy roars in frustration, and starts looking
around for someone else to fight.
He moves towards Akainu, seeking revenge for
Ace, just as the beams of light fall again,
but he is halted as a scream cuts across the
battlefield.
Back near the Sunny, a laser blast has fallen
near the gathered straw hats.
Smoke fills the air, and Luffy can see Sanji
holding an unconscious Nami, dodging between
strikes of light as the crew retreats to the
Sunny.
Suddenly, Luffy snaps out of his battle rage.
Usopp shouts at Luffy to come back.
And Zoro leaps down from the fortress carrying
Garp’s body.
Luffy takes another look towards the Red Line
and once again declares war on the world government.
Luffy shares a look with Shanks and then departs,
picking up Usopp as they return to the Sunny
and escape.
But this is far from the final battle.
Now that Luffy has even more motivation to
come after the world government, he and Akainu
are guaranteed to clash one final time, which
might well be the hardest battle for Luffy
in the entire story.
That’s because as we just saw in this battle,
the fleet admiral has one of the most overpowered
devil fruits in One Piece.
In fact, all of the admirals have ridiculously
strong devil fruits, which actually leaves
us with another super interesting question:
what do you think would have happened if instead
of his own devil fruit, Luffy had eaten one
of the admirals’ fruits?
And you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching.